What exactly is Project Butterfly?
Is Vigilante as crazy as he acts?
And how did Peacemaker survive the events
of "The Suicide Squad?"
Here's a quick explainer about where the first
three episodes of Peacemaker leave our patriotic
hero.
"Hey, the reason I'm excited?
It is normal."
If you didn't catch his appearance in James
Gunn's quasi-reboot "The Suicide Squad" when
it premiered last summer, "Peacemaker" helpfully
brings you up to speed by showcasing exactly
what the title character's all about:
"I cherish peace with all my heart."
stabs/shoots guys.
"I don't care how many men, women, and children
I need to kill to get it."
What else do you need to know?
After the battle against Starro the Conqueror
in Corto Maltese, Peacemaker is more or less
right as rain, despite getting shot in the throat, and getting
a building dropped on him.
"You're shot and a building falls on you and
all you have to replace is a clavicle?
You're the luckiest man alive."
After getting recaptured shortly after leaving
the hospital, Peacemaker's once again back
working for the government, though Amanda
Waller's not his commanding officer this time.
Peacemaker's new boss is Clemson Murn, a mercenary
with a dark reputation.
But it's not all new in "Peacemaker" – the
first hour of the series brings a number of
familiar faces back from Task Force X, including
Emilia Harcourt, John Economos, and, briefly,
a cameo from Amanda Waller herself.
We also meet a new member of the team, Leota
Adebayo, Peacemaker's racist father, Auggie
Smith; and Peacemaker's best human friend-slash-biggest-fan
Vigilante.
Let's take a look at where they all end up
in the first three episodes of "Peacemaker."
After following Harcourt to a bar, Peacemaker
makes a series of passes at his co-worker,
none of which work out.
Though Peacemaker is immediately attracted
to Harcourt, he becomes even more smitten
when she violently takes down a man who attacks
her.
Harcourt later gives Peacemaker a piece of
her mind – not that he totally gets what
she has to say.
"I have no interest in you, other than your
ability to fight for us.
Just because you're handsome, doesn't mean
you're not a piece-of-sh-t murderer."
"You think I'm handsome?"
When Peacemaker begs for a no-strings-attached
deal between the two of them, Harcourt appears
to grow even less interested and leaves.
While Peacemaker spends a significant amount
of time in the first episode focusing on sex,
Harcourt appears laser-focused on the finer
details of her new job.
She sees her placement on this specific task
force as punishment for her participation
in the mutiny against Amanda Waller in "The
Suicide Squad" and wants to prove herself
all over again.
As Waller herself later says, "Barbie's ambitious
– watch out for her."
Somewhat surprisingly, Viola Davis has a short
cameo in the first episode as Amanda Waller.
She appears in a short video call with Leota,
who, in addition to working as Waller's eyes
and ears on this mission, also happens to
be her daughter.
In keeping with her usual M.O., Waller is
once again playing a game outside the bounds
of the stated mission.
During her FaceTime call with Leota, Waller
commands her to hide a forged diary in Peacemaker's
trailer, for reasons that are initially known
only to her.
The exact purpose of the diary may not be
made immediately clear, but given the crying
child on the cover, it's likely to paint a
less-than-flattering picture of Peacemaker's
inner psyche.
But to what end?
While Amanda Waller's exact plan in the "Peacemaker"
series remains unclear in the first three
episodes, it seems certain that Waller will
seek to double cross Peacemaker and the rest
of the team eventually.
Leota's not the only character in "Peacemaker"
with an interesting parent who is difficult
to deal with.
"Terminator 2" star Robert Patrick plays Peacemaker's
appallingly racist father, Auggie.
When Peacemaker first arrives at his dad's
home, his dad is visibly displeased to see
him.
While Auggie is briefly amused at the story
of Bloodsport's childhood trauma, his main
response to his son's war stories is rooted
in disappointment.
At his son's insistence, Auggie gives him
another Peacemaker-branded helmet.
As it turns out, Peacemaker's new helmet ends
up coming his way at just the right time.
After getting rejected by Harcourt, Peacemaker
goes home with Annie, a random woman at the
bar.
Unfortunately, as their casual encounter is
on the cusp of wrapping up, that same woman
seems to go completely feral, stabbing Peacemaker
and throwing him through a wall.
It isn't until Peacemaker is reunited with
his helmet that he is able to gain the upper
hand by activating a new feature: the sonic
boom.
Considering how effective Augie's helmet tech
seems to be in this first episode, we can't
help but wonder if these other helmets will
be utilized at some other point this season.
The other power-up options in the lab offer
features as varied as a full body force field,
an underwater breathing apparatus, and X-ray
vision tech.
In a post-credits sequence, Auggie even shows
Peacemaker a helmet that literally just infects
its wearer with scabies– just because.
"Why would I want scabies?"
"To challenge yourself.
Every man should have scabies once in his
life."
The motivations for Annie Sturphausen's attack
on Peacemaker in the first episode aren't
entirely clear to the team at first.
Murn notes that the entire operation has been
kept off the books and he can't understand
how anyone could have known that Peacemaker
was a part of it.
Harcourt suggests that Amanda Waller might
have been behind it.
After Leota insists that it's not Waller,
Harcourt even begins to question Leota's placement
on the mission.
Eventually, however, Peacemaker remembers
that he caught Annie reviewing the classified
materials provided to him by Murn, including
a dossier detailing the mission to assassinate
a sitting U.S. Senator.
While Harcourt is proven wrong in her initial
accusations against Leota, this specific encounter
has clearly raised her suspicions of her newest
colleague.
We can't imagine that Harcourt or any of the
other team members will react positively when
they find out that Waller and Leota are keeping
an important part of the mission plan a secret.
We can't call it entirely shocking to discover
that Peacemaker's father is a character like
White Dragon.
Auggie Smith isn't exactly excited to see
his son return home and he's quickly revealed
to be a vile homophobe and racist.
Now that Auggie finds himself in prison after
John Economos frames him for Peacemaker's
crimes, he is shown to command a vast number
of fiercely loyal white supremacist followers.
In some ways, this is a fitting adaptation
from the "Peacemaker" comic book series, in
which, Peacemaker's father, Wolfgang Schmidt,
is a former commandant of a Nazi concentration
camp during World War II.
Since the last concentration camp was liberated
by the Allies in May of 1945 and "Peacemaker"
is set in the present day, the math wouldn't
quite allow for the same origin story without
some changes.
In the comics, William Heller (aka White Dragon)
is unrelated to Peacemaker, but considering
the comic character's white supremicist motivations
and appearances in the "Suicide Squad" comic
books, this new configuration turns out to
be a natural fit.
Peacemaker is definitely one of those characters
who just seems to stumble into Earth-shattering
revelations.
After a long set of failures, Vigilante convinces
Peacemaker to let loose by celebrating his
release from prison with a mixture of controlled
substances, firearms, and explosives.
However, the day's festivities don't stop
Peacemaker from mistakenly learning more about
his upcoming mission.
While smoking marijuana with Vigilante and
Amber, Peacemaker starts fiddling around with
the alien-looking device he stole from Annie's
house.
When Peacemaker touches a button on the device,
it quickly expands and forms what appears
to be a tiny spaceship.
By the time the second episode wraps up, it's
unclear who or what purpose such a small vessel
could serve – but it has to be tied to Project
Butterfly somehow.
Episode 3 puts the deadly capabilities of
Vigilante on display for the first time.
Following Peacemaker's inability to pull the
trigger at the home of Senator Royland Goff,
Vigilante takes control of the mission by
executing three of the four targets.
After Peacemaker and Vigilante are captured
by Goff, Vigilante is unmasked and tortured.
Unfortunately for Vigilante, Peacemaker refuses
to give up any information, even going so
far as to tell Goff to basically do his worst,
torture-wise.
"Does that change your mind?"
"Sorry pal – not for sale."
"What?"
"Give it all you got!"
Vigilante is visibly shocked when Peacemaker
refuses to spare him any torture and appears
genuinely hurt at Peacemaker's lack of empathy
for him.
Given Peacemaker's prior actions, what could
possibly make Vigilante surprised by Peacemaker's
unflinching response?
Maybe Vigilante really is as delusional as
he's seemed to be.
Still, even if Vigilante is Peacemaker's number
one fan, losing part of a pinky toe is bound
to drive a wedge into even the hardiest of
friendships.
It doesn't seem like these two would-be superheroes
are quite that close to begin with.
"Dude, I'm your best friend."
"No, you're not."
To quote Ned Leeds of "Spider-Man: Homecoming",
most people would probably agree that John
Economos seems like an archetypical "guy in
the chair."
"Can I be your guy in the chair?"
"What?"
"You know how there's a guy with a headset
telling the other guy where to go?"
However, Episode 3 forces Economos to quite
literally jump out of his chair and face a
threat directly.
As Harcourt, Leota, and Murn move in on the
house where Peacemaker and Vigilante are held
hostage by a Butterfly, Economos realizes
that Judo Master is escaping the scene in
a vehicle.
John ultimately rises to the occasion, crashing
the team's van directly into Judomaster's
car and later pummeling the martial artist
with a tire iron.
That might be a big win for John's ego, but
the bigger question is where Judo Master was
driving to.
Before Goff starts to torture Vigilante for
answers, he tells Judo Master,
"Take the tunnel to the forest.
From there, get to Glen Tyler and let them
know what's occurred here."
"Yes."
Presumably these are other Butterflies, maybe
even more important ones than the senator.
Once they find out about Peacemaker's mission,
how are they going to react?
After Peacemaker gains the upper-hand against
Senator Goff, he fires a single shotgun blast
into Goff's face.
And that's that, right?
In most cases, this would mean the end of
Goff's character, but not on "Peacemaker."
As Peacemaker and Vigilante prepare to reunite
with the rest of the team upstairs, the two
notice a small creature crawling out of the
face of the late senator.
As the creature takes to the sky with a flapping
of its wings, Peacemaker knowingly remarks,
"Oh, Project Butterfly."
That's when the episode ends with a tease
that "suspected butterflies" are all over
the world.
Episode 3's reveal of the literal butterfly
inside Senator Goff's head is a major clue
to the entire mission at large, a subject
about which Peacemaker actually knows frighteningly
little.
Is the goal to kill all butterflies, or just
the ones that Amanda Waller wants dead?
When Peacemaker gives Murn intel that proves
that the seemingly happy family of four is
actually entirely composed of Butterflies,
the task force captain quickly relays orders
to kill them all.
Does this mean all Butterflies are as dangerous
as the woman who attacks Peacemaker in Episode
1?
Considering the fact that we've only seen
them attack Peacemaker either in self-defense
or after discovering his assassination plan,
they might not even be malevolent.
Regardless, given everything we've learned
about the group so far, it seems fairly obvious
that literally anyone, even people we think
we know, could secretly be a butterfly.
Many of the post-credits scenes in "Peacemaker"
work as jokey extensions of scenes from the
episode, rather than material that's critical
to the plot.
Episode 3's post-credits sequence takes us
back to the moment when Vigilante reveals
himself behind the bushes outside the home
of Senator Goff.
As Harcourt prepares for the possibility that
Vigilante could ruin the entire mission, she
issues a menacing threat.
"If you f— up this mission, I will kill
your f—in' family."
"Ok.
Good luck!
A little late for that...
You guys got beer?"
Considering this character's particular proclivity
for violence, it doesn't seem like a big stretch
to guess that Vigilante might even be the
one responsible for his family's deaths.
In the "Vigilante" comic series, Adrian Chase
takes on the Vigilante persona after his wife
and children are murdered by the mob.
While it's possible this series is simply
alluding to the original character's comic
history, we think it's more likely this character
has an intensely more absurd background.
In Episode 2, Vigilante admits to Peacemaker
that, in prior years, he would have killed
him for smoking marijuana, and he seems similarly
extreme in his response to other crimes.
"When I found out someone murdered an innocent
person or sold someone heroin or did some
grafitti and I kill that person…"
Perhaps Vigilante's family members simply
chose a bad time to jaywalk?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.